a relaxed atmosphere for this the last
of the week's hearings the Danish
Commissioner designate for competition
margretta Vesta gir was happy enough
joking around with journalists and she
turned to the business of the day
hammering out the core values that will
guide her to ensure the rule of law for
this former minister of the economy
competition offers an opportunity for
the EU new competition policy plays a
crucial role to help us start growing
again I am in favor of strong
competition and I will not constrain
large companies from competing on merits
but I will not hesitate to challenge
behavior a major players unduly
squeezing out smaller competitors not
forgetting of course that no one can
breach competition rules which occupy a
place at the heart of the European
Commission's work vertie
internationalism des veterans resist in
a debt setting or patient whether
there's political work safety what is
important is of course that whenever a
business operates in Europe it's the
same rules no matter who's the owner
who's the shareholder who's in charge
when you operate in Europe is European
rules but MEP s wanted more detailed
answers on certain questions starting
with state aid for the banking sector I
think it is important to get out of this
sort of very very special situation and
where taxpayers were asked to pay again
and again and again to banks who had
taken enormous risks in a very very
critical period of time
one other underexplored issue in the
field of competition search engine is
and personal data have rapidly become
one of the most valuable resources of
our economy we would need a new and
integral approach approach to competent
competition rules in the age of big data
do you agree I think that here we find
an issue which is very much sort of in a
zone between competition and data
protection and personal rights and also
personal freedoms we should
in much deeper understanding of these
markets one of many answers which
clearly addressed some of the concerns
of MEP s this evening it was a very
constructive hearing so it was a good
atmosphere better than other earrings we
had so in this sense I'm satisfied my
great investigator her first steps in
the European bubble as a parliamentary
trainee 25 years ago